robot heads dangerous blood and bing
bong all these references in the first
episode of she-hulk mean something big
viewers who are otherwise unfamiliar
with she-hulk may be surprised when
jennifer walters looks directly at the
camera and says
it's true i am a hulk longtime marvel
comics fans however will happily
recognize she-hulk breaking the fourth
wall to acknowledge she's a fictional
character as head writer jessica gao
revealed to total film the fourth wall
demolishing series flea bag is a major
influence on she-hulk attorney at law
but jennifer walters has been having
meta-fictional adventures since john
byrne's sensational she-hulk number one
hit the stands in 1989. gao told variety
that jennifer's rule-breaking
irreverence is rooted in burns
reinvention of the character the
episode's opening scene sets the tone
for the series with even more comic book
references nikki ramos jennifer's
paralegal and best friend suggests she
show a savage look a nod to jennifer's
very first marvel comics series savage
she-hulk jennifer's rehearsed closing
argument for an upcoming case also
includes the phrase those with the most
power
have the most to answer for that sounds
quite similar to spider-man's motto with
great power
comes great responsibility
a flashback reveals she-hulk's harrowing
origin while on vacation jennifer and
her cousin bruce banner encounter a
spaceship from the planet zakar where
hulk found fame as a gladiator in thor
ragnarok which forces their car off a
cliff jennifer pulls bruce from the
wreckage inadvertently mixing his blood
with hers and triggering her first
transformation into she-hulk
the scene is a dramatic update of
she-hulk's origin and is first depicted
in 1980 savage hulk number one there
bruce gives jennifer an emergency blood
transfusion after she's shot by a
mobster the danger of anyone potentially
coming into contact with bruce's blood
is established in 2008's the incredible
hulk in which bruce is hiding in brazil
and working in a bottling factory blood
from his cut finger contaminates a
bottle of soda which then gives an
elderly man played by stan lee gamma
sickness so jennifer's inadvertent blood
transfusion is a callback to a
significant moment in bruce's early
history and a modernization of her
classic comic book origin this time
jennifer becomes she-hulk because she
risks her life to save bruce giving her
more agency and control over her story
after her first night as she-hulk
jennifer wakes up on an isolated beach
house in mexico where bruce has taken
her to recover walking around the house
she sees a battered gray and gold head
belonging to an iron legion droid
developed by tony stark the iron legion
appears in 2015's avengers age of ultron
as a peacekeeping force at aids avengers
on an early mission to sokovia after
tony and bruce designed the advanced ai
system ultron it gains self-awareness
and activates inside an iron legion
droid
ultron leads the rest of the automated
army to attack the unprepared avengers
in the basement laboratory of the mexico
beach house bruce explains to jennifer
that the house was a gift from the
now-deceased tony stark and that they
spent time here in the years following
the blip tony's influence is visible
throughout the house especially in the
star-tech used in the lab and the
initials he carved into the bar and a
tiny mostly drank just sat around
complaining about steve oh steve the
iron legion helmet is a bittersweet
reminder of the two avengers combined
hopes and failures
she hulk attorney at law is adept at
dropping pop culture references
including nods to other disney
properties in the premiere smart hulk
explains that jennifer's transformations
are triggered by intense emotion in an
effort to gauge her transformational
threshold he traps her in a booth with
buzzing saw blades but jennifer has a
better idea put on a pixar movie when
bing bong jumps out of the wagon
pixar likely needs no introduction the
animation studio has produced some of
the most widely beloved and tear-jerking
family films of the last three decades
this is a sly bit of corporate synergy
pixar and marvel are both owned by
disney and it also means much more
inside out specifically stars riley a
young girl struggling with a move she
steered through life by the personified
emotions of joy sadness disgust fear and
anger one of the movie's biggest themes
is the danger of allowing one emotion to
dominate the others
something of a particular relevance to
the hulks whose transformations are
triggered by fear and anger the scene
with bing bong riley's imaginary friend
that jennifer mentions symbolizes the
loss of childhood innocence like riley
jennifer is adjusting to a significant
change in her life but where she-hulk is
concerned the growing pains are very
literal
the first episode of she-hulk features a
confrontation between cousins jennifer
and bruce guaranteed to leave marvel
fans smiling not only does the audience
get to see the two jade giants square
off for the first time bruce unleashes a
classic hulk move that hasn't been seen
on screen since 2008's the incredible
hulk for the record
i really didn't want to do this
at this point bruce slaps his palms
together creating a blast of wind
powerful enough to send her flying
this is hulk's famous thunderclap attack
first used to devastating effect in
1962's incredible hulk number four it
creates a shock wave powerful enough to
strike down enemies level cities and
even in 2011's incredible hulk's number
634 put the formidable dragon fin fang
boom out to pasture but the thunderclap
can save people too in the movie the
incredible hulk he claps to extinguish
the flames engulfing it down helicopter
saving betty ross and thunderbolt ross
after picking herself up she hulk tries
her hand at the thunderclap with less
than perfect results she soon gets the
hang of it allowing her to show bruce
what his signature move feels like on
the receiving end
[Music]
you